although 70 percent of
american adults have received at least
one dose of cob vaccine and
19 that is not the case among
vaccine-eligible
students preparing to return to
school
report and mary world counselor to the
white house on the hobbit 19 says
less than 40 percent
of 12 to 15 year olds are vaccinated and
less than half of 16 to
17 year olds have received the vaccine those
statistics are causing concern
as the number  of cases of kobe 19
is increasing throughout the country due
to the delta variant a person who on
wall says that when they return to
schools, students, teachers and
other employees must continue to wear
masks even if they are vaccinated
cusco the director of the
control centers  and disease prevention
doctor rosa world ends key explains that
the vaccines in combination with the
masks will help to keep
the open and  healthy students
even so the white house says it will not
implement a nationwide mandate for masks
or vaccines in schools
saying that decision will be up to
state and municipal governments
reporting in washington
alexandra limon